la journée de mobilisation en france
plus de 170 rassemblements sont prévus
aujourd'hui un peu partout dans le pays
des manifestations à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats et d'organisations
de jeunesse pour réclamer des hausses de
salaires à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle la crise sanitaire et le
retour de l'inflation ont relancé le
débat sur l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat des français on retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter hélène masquelier
à vous suivez hélène le rassemblement
parisien est ce que la mobilisation est
au rendez vous
oui sophy comme vous pouvez le voir ils
sont déjà assez nombreux ici place de la
bastille à avoir répondu à l'appel
le public comme le privé il ya ici et
toutes les professions ils sont là tous
pour réclamer une hausse globale des
salaires comme vous l'avez dit et parmi
leurs revendications ils demandent
notamment une revalorisation du smic à
1700 euros nets et une augmentation de
l'ensemble des minima sociaux de 400
euros il demande également que le rsa
deviennent accessibles aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans en tout cas ce qu'il
demande globalement c'est que leur
travail soit véritablement reconnu ici
et il y a une certaine colère qui
s'exprime
je vous propose d'écouter certains
d'entre eux
voient que les grandes sociétés ils ont
des multinationales qui assiettes des
sauges des milliards de milliards tu
vois et que ce qui amène cinq milliards
là c'est les travailleurs/ses les
travers qu'il a mais qui en même temps
tout le secteur c'est le travailleur qui
amène de l'argent cet argent là utilisé
autrement que de quelques uns des épées
les salariés nos revendications sont un
vrai statut de fonctionnaires parce
qu'on travaille pour l'éducation
nationale un vrai salaire à temps plein
on demande un recrutement massif d'un et
sache on demande des formations en ce
moment nous parle d'une augmentation du
temps de travail d'une réduction des
congés
voilà donc c'est aussi pour être visible
dès il dire que les animateurs sont là
qu'on s'occupe aussi d'enfants on
soutient les enseignants et en même
temps
on va là ont envie d'être visible on
envie de dire que l'on veut pas
travailler plus pour avoir le même
salaire on veut pas une réduction de
congé on veut plutôt lent verse une
augmentation de salaire et garder garder
nos acquis sociaux finalement quand on
peut suivre aisément nombreux et silvia
monfort on peut faire bouger les choses
la preuve c'est qu'il a commencé à
reculer sur un projet il en faire un
deuxième c'est pas sûr qu'il est là
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout mais l'a pour
l'instant il est sous l'éteignoir
puisque l élection présidentielle en
trois mois et il va pas se mettre à dos
la france entière à l'aube avant les
élections ce n'est pas possible ça va
revenir après on va l'avoir et comme
tous les coups les mauvais coups se
passe pendant les vacances on va avoir
ce à la rentrée à quelques semaines de à
quelques semaines de la présidentielle
c'est donc la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui s'invite dans la campagne et
il ya quelques personnalités politiques
qui devraient faire le déplacement
notamment et yannick jadot fabien
roussel ou encore jean luc mélenchon
c'est donc une mobilisation dans un
contexte de baisse globale du pouvoir
d'achat sachant que 5 % des ménages les
plus modestes ont perdu jusqu'à 0,5 pour
cent du pouvoir d'achat tandis que la
dernière grande mobilisation
interprofessionnelle commente au 5
octobre dernier on va donc voir si celle
ci sera aussi suivie en tout cas nous
allons suivre le cortège tout l'après
midi le départ est prévu dans quelques
minutes direction bercy et or aura
beaucoup à leur merci beaucoup hélène la
masse cadier